[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
you know you come in here
no do your location your location shame
me
you're location-shaming because i don't
live in a fancy house like all your
fancy friends like joe rogan and
everybody right you come in here you i
[ __ ] my girl
you're coming here you know what i mean
so major comedy and podcast drama going
down last week is brennan shaw bobby lee
kalila tiger belly brian callan the
fighter and the kid joe rogan tim dillon
dan soder the h3 podcast so many
different characters and twists and
turns different accusations and
allegations we're gonna get to the
bottom of all of it it's confusing it
goes back a few months and maybe it's
still not over who knows but we're gonna
get to the bottom of it we're gonna play
every clip we're going to show every
receipt and we're going to figure out
what really went down between brendan
bobby and kalyala okay so back in
january trash tuesdays comes out with
episode 49. trash tuesdays is kalila's
other podcast she does with annie
lederman esther pavitski
she does it with them and it's more of a
female oriented podcast they talk about
girl stuff whatever this and that they
were talking about this guy this
comedian who had hit on both annie and
kalyla in the past from kalila it came
from dms which she said on uh trash
tuesday was about three years ago um
these same dms
on when she talks about them on tiger
belly she mentions they were like seven
years ago so there's a chance that they
continued seven to three years but
there's also a chance that she just
misspoke different dates annie though
said that this this guy this comedian
is a unfunny comedian
after she said
it's an unfunny comedian kleila goes
that's a big clue that's a big clue and
then she says that this guy asked to
walk him to his truck
so implying that there was going to be
some sexual activity going down after
maybe a little blowy in the truck she
basically just trashes this unnamed
comedian as well as kalila when guys do
that it makes me so like you just think
i'm that big yeah i had a guy that was
like why don't you walk me to my truck
this married guy where i'm like and we
know him i'm not gonna say who it is but
um i know him why don't you give me a w
why don't you give like you should walk
me to my truck i'm like so what i can
blow you like wait who was it oh but
it's just like it's like why would i
wait i love that we have the same people
that yes the same ones coming
for you oh he came for me so hard and we
know his chick and like the thing that i
think is like at least a little bit
better
the fact
esther he's coming for you don't worry
that is it's just crazy now that you
washed your hair
maybe nothing on new year's eve while he
was having dinner with his family he was
like what are you doing tonight this
year maybe three years ago
he was like what are you doing tonight i
was like
left him on ready but he's like i hate
that i'm with my
in-laws right now do you want to go
he did
is like he thinks you're gonna be a
partner in crime like for me i was like
single i'm like why would i like it's
not like we're deviants together it's
like you think because i was thinking
about like if we go to your truck okay
like let's say i was like in which i was
never in at all let's say i was in it i
love it so wait we walked in my car i
finished my spot being very good at
comedy you not being good at comedy and
then that's a clue by the way i don't
want like to be seen with you i don't
the biggest clue you could ever give and
like so you're not gonna comedy and then
you want me to walk you to your car like
so i let's say okay so i'm literally
like i leave a sea of adoring fans okay
like i leave a sea of like people being
like can i take pictures with you you're
amazing where'd you get your outfit it's
esther club you can get it on or it's
sleepover by esther you can get it on
our website
on ice
i'm like in the middle of just like joy
you want me to stop like what i've
worked my ass off to do
you want me to stop doing that so i can
walk you
to a car that's more expensive than the
one i'm living in at that time
to then
to what suck your dick like i'm not
coming in this situation like what is
this where's my orgasm in this scenario
there's no what is the incentive but
this is what i'm saying i'm like what
would i get out of this that i get to
suck your unfunny dick like i'm good
i'm just so
traumatized by even when you say his
name just like years of
and i i have the i still have the
receipts and one day i'm going to just
submit it to do more so two weeks after
that bren shop goes on flagrant 2 in an
attempt to uh promote his special andrew
schultz asks him when are you going to
bury the trash tuesday beef what's going
on with trash tuesday bren shaw
basically says there's no beef he denies
that he ever hit on andy lederman or
asked to walk or do it any truck or try
to do anything basically just says the
whole thing is made up there's no beef
i'm good with kalila i'm one of bobby's
friends mind you they're talking about
this after the supposed phone call which
we'll get to later had already occurred
what's with the trash tuesday beef when
are we going to settle the trash tuesday
beef it's settled as far as you know did
you try to [ __ ]
any letterman to your truck nah that
does not make sense no no
no okay so then follow up why is it why
does it not make sense why does that was
easy
you know
it's her perspective and i get it
perspective for for it to get back to me
it has to get out of control as far as
the annie stuff goes that's where i do
have to defend myself okay i have to you
know
you guys didn't say my name
right i get or you but you'll leave it
to me the line was what am i gonna do
suck your unfunny dick and then i i came
back as far as me latin but she uh again
i didn't see it but as far as she's
saying i i asked her to walk in my car
give her a ride no i i think that
i you know i cannot speak for her yeah i
can only tell you
i'm saying i can only tell you what was
said on that particular point and again
if that's how she feels she's validated
feel like that
and i'm telling you that's that never
happened what was said was that there
was a guy he was unfunny i came back
with oh that's a big clue
and
that's something about a peach emoji
and then but my thing with that clyde do
you think that's nice oh no
but i didn't say your name
but it's it's hang on one second brendan
let me let me ask you this
if we're having this discussion about
something that happened in the past and
we're having a giggly little girl talk
where is the crime in that there's no
crime you can do whatever you want right
i have no issue with that go ahead okay
yeah no issue with it all right i'm i'm
just saying is that nice that's all i
have gone to you and said if i could go
back if i had known that a tiny little
giggly girl talk was going to spiral
into this i would have wired my mouth
shut
but in my heart of hearts while you may
think it's not nice and now i admit not
the nicest thing to say it was just an
anecdote sure so that was i didn't think
much of it
on saying that because hitting on
someone it's just simply not a
cancelable offense that was my
justification for it who the [ __ ] cares
who hits on who seven years ago i had
fake tits then they were shiny you liked
them you dm'd me
you said sorry [ __ ] it right as far as
kalila goes you know me and her had a
long conversation on the phone we are
good man yeah no one's suing anybody
these narratives online you know it's
it's a it's a
you know it's like a [ __ ] soap show
they want this drama there's no drama
like bobby lee is one of my close
friends i mean bobby talk no one's been
more supportive when i started than
bobby lee dude they said that you had
like some dirt on her or something like
that i have to have note i don't know so
maybe we don't know each other that way
they're making this up or whatever yeah
but when it comes to kalila it's like i
don't know again i don't i don't
subscribe to social media so if she's
getting that news yeah and she
subscribes to it
i would be upset too and that's why i
told her see i'm like i get it so i mean
you know some stuff you don't have to
tell the public you know what i'm saying
like i'm me and kali they're cool
bobby's one of my closest friends man
yeah so it's like with that stuff and
you got to realize when i was coming to
comedy and again i get all of it when
you have this do you drive a truck
no yeah
you don't even drive a truck
hold on you don't even have a truck no
here's no i have a bronco that i got six
eight minutes
no that's eight months ago that's eight
months so you didn't own a truck before
then no i i had a truck no hold up i had
a truck i had a truck
i got rid of it after two weeks back on
february 23rd apparently brennan schaub
had texted bobby lee that he's been
harassed on reddit and online for the
past six years that he's sick and tired
of it that he spent half a million
dollars on monster lawyers who are going
to get the job done at all costs and
that he has friends in dark places who
are going to make sure that this is all
resolved um he texts that to bobby
and bobby just responds with okay i'll
tell kalyala
bobby having nothing to do with it
really not knowing what this is about
just like all right i know that you are
beefing with kalila because of these
stories that they shared about you then
the next day brennan calls bobby and
tells him to tell kalila
that on the next episode of trash
tuesdays he would like the girls to come
out and say
brenden shop was not the comedian that
we were talking about as his drama's
kind of unfolding it comes out that
brendan was threatening to expose kalila
for something that he had this inside
information this dirt on her and if she
didn't come out on trash tuesdays and
say that he was not the guy that was
hitting on her and doing the walking me
to the truck thing if that was fake he
wants them to say that on their platform
or else he's going to release this
information and that information was
that kalila and bobby had started this
open relationship that she was seeing
another guy in hawaii i'm not sure if
brandon knew that bobby knew but he
definitely didn't know that the other
girls on the podcast knew and that it
was kind of already in the public um so
they were not threatened by this
information uh but they were also we're
not willing to share this you know on
their podcast with the public so
they ended up coming out and saying that
in h3 kind of getting ahead of the story
but this was the information that was
apparently weaponized against them by
brendan
this is also just a side note i have
always wondered you know watching their
show for many years what would happen if
they broke up like kalila just leaves
like obviously it's more of bobby's show
like bobby is the headlining commit
actual comedian name that we're going to
see and does most of the talking i'm
sure kala has a lot to do behind the
scenes and stuff you know she says it's
her business a lot and is very very
proud of tiger belly but i always
wondered like if they broke up i wonder
what would happen to the show and it
turns out they were broken up for a few
episodes
and like fully broken up not even open
relationship according to klyla and they
just kept going on as co-hosts so
i guess that answers that question tiger
belly uh will will be safe no matter
what happens to bobby and kyla's
relationship moving forward i didn't
text by that mean bobby spoke on the
phone and he said i didn't he said i
said can i say dude i'm getting a lot of
[ __ ] about this i'm married with kids i
said it's not good i said in bobby's
exact words i'll fix this whatever that
means okay so we didn't
we didn't confirm nor deny
um we figured it would die out in a week
anyway i agree
um
on march 3rd
you text bobby asking if he's handled
the quote-unquote kalila [ __ ] yet
because you're still getting negative
comments in this text chain you said i
don't want to have to get nasty with her
but if i have no choice
this is all direct quotes i can def play
that game and this was referring to the
months that bobby and i were in an open
relationship thinking that that was
somehow going to
directly hurt me
obviously obviously i mean it's like you
know the open relationship
you and i we ca we were that's not
for the po was for the we even talked
about it's not for the public
consumption right because it was
delicate it was a delicate thing he was
also we're going back on drugs
there's so many different so many
different elements elements to it right
it was a dark time it was very fragile
so it was you know we actually broke up
for a while yes in fact schultz knew
that because when schultz came here we
were broken up yeah so
and you guys did or didn't talk about
this on the podcast we never talked
the first time we've ever talked about
it out loud was h3 which is a couple of
days ago okay
so and um
it's something that i was going to die
to the grave you know and so that's what
this would have all been solved if you
and i would have talked direct like we
did a week ago with your timeline
but before you go on the real quick can
i say this yeah the information i got
that open relationship
that's not a it's not like anybody did a
crime that's not really breaking news i
can't hold that over your head the other
information you gave me was is is the
the bad one
which i
don't want to get into okay okay that i
don't want to bring up that's not fair
to you guys or anybody we can get into
that wait what is that other thing yeah
we can get into that
the other day hold on let me let me
actually
probably let let's assume that it's the
same old narrative of me being a gold
digger and stealing money from bobby
within those lines we talked about it
yeah you know that spoke about this and
you told me oh yes i mean let's let's be
real that is an old tired story bobby
call your accountants so then on april
13th there's a trash tuesday's live
stream where uh kalila annie all the
girls are on there and they're talking
about how they might be sued they might
be being sued by a bigger comedian a
bigger podcaster how there's this
podcast drama and it revolves around a
podcast with three girls that are being
sued by a bigger comedian now why did
they think they were being sued because
of the text that bobby had showed kalila
about brendan schaub saying that he's
hiring f 500 000 worth of monster
lawyers and his friends in dark places
and also apparently because there was an
article in this gossip website
um armoire i forget what's called
i should probably just look at what's
called real quick it's in these clips
it's called
so they read this thing on dumois which
is a gossip website that said that this
podcast with three girls is being sued
by a bigger podcaster and they
apparently just assumed that the article
was talking about them
now something interesting to note is
earlier in this video
when kawhile is talking about having all
the receipts of dms with brendan she
jokingly jokingly throws out there one
day she would love to send it to dumois
um
coincidence probably but i've never
heard of dumois in my life and it it's
funny that the the place the gossip
website she was joking about sending all
this stuff is what leaked something to
cause her to think she's being sued the
other thing is i've never been sued but
like
do you not know that you're being like
doesn't someone alert you besides like a
celebrity gossip website that is half
full of like not true [ __ ] anyway like
wouldn't you know that you're being sued
immediately like before the public or
before a gossip website i don't know how
being sued works i just feel like maybe
the tiger belly lawyer would tell them
exactly hey you guys are being sued like
you it doesn't seem like something that
you have to like guess like i think that
might be us i think he might be suing us
like wouldn't it already be in the
middle of that
that might be completely off base i
don't know anything about that but
that's just what i was assuming as a
young boy i don't know so dumas is a
celebrity like gossip account and a
couple maybe about a month ago they
posted something about
our show it this post on the gossip site
said like this popular podcast which
were like hey girl thanks for calling us
popular and uh it said that we had a lot
of controversy behind the scenes and
tension that we had we were a part of a
big scandal
and that the tension you were feeling
was real nobody felt any tension
but
that scandal that they were referring to
had nothing to do with the three of us
and it was because
it's potentially we were threat being
threatened uh a lawsuit
uh
and i'm like scared to even say that we
can't really we just won't say the name
right but we won't yeah but someone was
like behind the scenes threatening to
sue us
even the thing that started it all was
really just an anonymous anecdote i
don't see this did that blow up that
person who threatened us i'll say this
you think you have a one over me i
[ __ ] dare you [ __ ]
i dare you let it out of your chest
because that is actually not a real
threat you think you're threatening me
but
it's kind of that information's already
out there you little [ __ ] yeah you can
confirm yeah she can confirm she can
confirm bobby it's just also i just want
to say this like my currency is not
money my currency and where i see value
power is in jokes so
i'm rich and you're broke [ __ ] so come
after me you've got nothing on me you
unfunny piece of [ __ ] there was a dumor
article that said there's um a girl
podcast that is going to going through a
lot of internal trouble because a much
bigger podcaster is trying to sue them
we assumed it was us
also based on the text that
bobby had showed me about you
spending half a million dollars on
monster lawyers i assumed oh of course
it had to be us well hold on so there's
an article where a big podcaster is
suing through
well it's in do more right jordan what's
that dumoa is a site that
picks up like insider information about
either like celebrities and whatnot i
think they picked up on the drama of um
just the whole trash tuesday podcast and
and
in in the art they don't say any names
or anything
but they they kind of add like little
hints and stuff along the way they give
you enough information to sort of yeah
anyways
um so during that live show the girls
the night talk about someone possibly
threatened to sue us we were really
under the beliefs
of that article no two things
this screenshot that you had sent bobby
that you're coming after
everyone spending half a million dollars
on monster lawyers that you have friends
in dark places
that you were um and then that article
added to that you're saying correct
gotcha um and then
i add
i add during the live stream show i said
this particular someone thinks he has
dirt on me and i say go ahead
expose me and i wasn't very nice and he
calls this person to someone unfunny and
i said and i called that person a little
[ __ ]
and a doubt kind of the outcome of that
it fueled more harassment towards you on
reddit
after the live show then on april 9th
some [ __ ] happened with andrew schultz
we don't get to know about it because
kalila says she doesn't want to drag him
into this but it's like come on man
andrew schultz is a character that we
really want to know about in all this
dude like come on
that's a good character i will skip
april 18 because it involves a dm
from schultz and i don't want to drag
him into this
okay
how are you going to bring that up and
then just brush over it don't even bring
it up if you're not willing to talk
about it i hate when people do that in
real life when they're about to tell a
story or say something and they ah never
mind and you're like you know what and
they go oh no no never mind i don't want
to get into it you're like well then
then why did you say it
i hate that anyway a few days after that
which was about three weeks ago from
today if you're trying to keep this all
straight in your head three weeks ago
from today is when brendan and uh brian
callan called bobby
and apparently this is a really
aggressive phone call this is like one
of the main things that people are upset
about um
brian callan and bren shop called up
bobby basically threatening his career
saying his career is over they're
exposing him they're gonna
tell rogan all the stuff that he's doing
that he's the mastermind behind this
subreddit for the last six years sending
death threats and hate to brendan and
his family
and it was a really really aggressive
phone call which i just think it's funny
to imagine like a three-man phone call
with two people like screaming at the
same time like holding holding the phone
like sharing it and just trying to get
their own thing in like [ __ ] you bobby
you piece of [ __ ] um your career's done
and then someone yeah yeah like it's
just one phone and they gotta like share
it and then they're also trying to hear
what bobby's saying and they're like
wait my turn i got something good to say
bobby was willing to brush this all
under the rug you know he was never
going to bring up the phone call he said
but on age three they went on the show
him and kalila went on the h3 podcast
he brought brendan shop
bobby just had really nice things to say
how fun he is how how much he helped him
when he started in comedy and how he's a
good friend that's what bobby said
kalila
does not let it go and neither does h3
he keeps like probing questions and like
trying to cause this drama which is kind
of what his show
is in a lot of ways i've heard i i i
shouldn't assume that but kalila does
not take the chance to end the
conversation when bobby says he's a good
friend he's funny this and that and just
is like can we please move on
you can just see the wheel string and
she goes one more thing and then she
keeps saying one more thing i'd like to
add until it turns into this 40 minute
clip of just all
laying it all out there you know and so
i don't i don't know if the flagrant two
clip would have started this same war
as what happened on age three it was a
phone call with other podcasters
and it was that's some [ __ ] they
flogged you bro enough flogged me they
threatened my career
they called me
a coward
a [ __ ] you've always been a [ __ ] i'm
sorry that's nice
and um
they said they would expose me they said
that all these things and i was in
oklahoma shooting a show
and i was at dinner and i was by myself
and i was getting it was very traumatic
for me and
it was based on
whatever they did on the live now
imagine now what's going to happen with
now this do you think we should i could
call him right now and get clarification
no no do not call him
wait we're all hey him and i are okay
now i don't i doubt i'm gonna say this
no after this no you will not be able to
i agree with that i promise you this and
this is this has opened
no no no no i'm not fine i'm fine or i'm
probably fine i'm totally fine but i'm
just saying that this has opened up a
world home i'm not a [ __ ] right i'm
just saying
the thing is is that you guys don't do
stand-up right no right so i'm always
around them yeah right
i always have so i'm trying to play it
politically right i feel like i was
assaulted for something that i didn't do
at all i don't know even know what the
[ __ ] they're talking about you truly
have nothing to do with it i have
nothing to do with and yet i was being
you know i mean um they put it all on
hill right because they're using you to
try to control what what kala's doing
right right so um you know i you know i
went to therapy and about it you know i
mean we talked about it yesterday
because it's like it was just so
traumatic and these were my friends and
i had no idea what the [ __ ] they were
talking about right and so
my whole thing was
let's never talk about it again
ever right and let's just brush it on
the rug so that i can go to comedy clubs
and look them in the eye and be
cordial right but now right this is a
whole nother
[ __ ] thing so when you guys called
you um it was you and brian and um
you said that i um that you guys my
career was going to be over um that you
guys have evidence you know i mean that
um that i'm some
reddit mastermind that there's you have
files and proof
that um you can trace you know
me from reddit back to my house the url
you know
um address and that i um
have been
for five and or six years have been um
coily and and you know mischiefly you
know
you know contributing to threads that
were um not contributing what didn't you
say was
well from what you had said that we were
responsible responsible right
and that um
you know that you were gonna expose me
to rogan and all these people
and then i should get a lawyer and that
i um i mean this is what you told me and
it and also just mind you
it was at a level 10 of rage it wasn't
like a soft-spoken like you know very
aggressive yeah it was extreme you know
i mean threats and then
you called kalila things i'd only want
to want to mention i did not i know you
didn't i would i and i haven't heard
what you guys said i've i don't talk
like that i would never call kalei of
that right brendan you called me that on
the phone call we had i did not call you
that right i did not no you don't know
what you don't know what he they said so
you can't
just brian apologized what brian said on
there and even i told him that was too
that was a lot it was a lot yeah it was
a lot
but what what i found to be um
heartbreaking was going into a character
assassination where you were saying not
you in particular i don't even know
remember what because i was such an
in in i was so trembling almost
um calling me a coward
weak
spineless
um
and my only defense to that is that i
just have my own way of dealing with the
world you know i mean because i
um grew up in such a traumatic childhood
i you know i try to be passive and i try
to not i mean i'm afraid of
confrontation as everyone knows in terms
of my character and um
you know
i said to brian days after
that assault um that
yeah i no longer want to be your friend
his friend um and did you guys speak on
the phone or yeah we just talked yeah
and he apologized he said yeah he did
apologize but um
yeah i mean he doesn't expect you to be
his friend yeah oh it's not it's done
bobby lee is somebody i love very much
we both do yes but bobby but people have
been talking on uh he he went online and
he he went on and talked about
somebody who spoke to him in a very
rough bullying manner okay
that wasn't anybody but me
i'm the guy i'm the one who did it
not not chris not theo not sam it was me
okay and the re and now now now here's
the second thing i want to say bobby is
100
right in his
anger at me in his in how he felt and
i'm 100 wrong i take full [ __ ]
responsibility for the way i spoke to
him which was
wrong there's no excuse okay
and and now i will give you now having
said that let me say it again and this
is what i said to bobby i bobby if i
didn't when did you i spoke to bobby i
tried to speak to him after you spoke to
kalila when i spoke to bobby i said to
him on the phone i believe you
and then i thought i don't know kalyana
i thought that she was and and let me
just say this
and i'm going to explain this but i want
to first own up to everything that i did
because what i did at the end of the day
the way i spoke to bobby who's somebody
i love
who didn't deserve the word nobody
deserves to be just attacked
and i'm going to tell you where i was
wrong and i'm going to get specific but
let me start once again by saying
me i'm the guy okay i take full
responsibility i was wrong
i said this to bobby i called him up and
bobby read me the riot act i think if he
had been in front of me he would have
[ __ ] punched me and and he's
justified and i said bobby you're
absolutely right i apologize i was wrong
klyla also was saying one of the bigger
issues in all this is that after all
this [ __ ] went down bren shop flew to
austin to tell joe rogan about all this
and to expose klyla and bobby and tiger
belly and to tell joe that kalil is a
gold digger and stealing money from
bobby and also to tell him that bobby
and tiger belly are responsible for all
this reddit hate and accusations and
threats on him and his career and
obviously joe's very powerful person in
podcasting so this is um a big
accusation to weigh against brendan and
it would be a really [ __ ] up thing of
brendan to do
especially with not without knowing 100
if that's true or not to go tell joe
that that's going to change his opinion
of these two forever you know uh people
that are trying to make it in podcasting
that's a kind of crazy thing to do but i
also think it's kind of weird to act
like joe's like the godfather of pogba i
mean in the way he is but in a way he's
not like
anyone can start a podcast you don't
have to have joe's permission joke and
hate your guts you're still allowed to
have a podcast i also don't think tiger
belly fans and jre fans even cross over
that much
maybe bad friends fans do more because
him and rogan and santino have more of a
relationship but like
i don't even think bobby's ever been on
rogan i don't even know what the
relationship like if rogan hated bobby
he could still go about doing his show
but it's still a really shitty thing of
brent to do if it's true however brennan
denies that i don't really know what to
believe i can't think that someone would
fly to another city just to tell someone
something in 2022 with
phones you know
like
he was going there to do a show to
promote his special um but
and then probably just brought that up
like if you have something to tell
someone you can just no one is gonna fly
somewhere to tell someone something
in my opinion
however he could have not just shared
that dirt while he was there already
doing this show to promote his special
so when you said
i i flew to austin and tell rogan about
this yeah that's my next question no
okay can i come yeah yeah yeah flew to
rogan to do the his show
okay this is uh
aside from that okay copy that that
makes sense and i want you know as they
look you in the eye
when i would tell them
i i would
preface with every every time i go i
don't think bob and kyle are involved
the tiger belly email is on there okay
and every every single time never ever
and i swear my kids never went clyde was
a gold digger cut none of it can we just
do a new segment real quick so but he'll
talk in the new segment go ahead
right
new segment
that's it
that's this yeah yeah yeah that was i
just need to do it i have oc i have a
pension breaker yeah yeah
but then also when you when you went to
so
you know you got to remember too rogan's
like an older brother to me you when i
do anything i call rogan that's how
that's how i operate yeah yeah i asked
his advice on this right and then um you
know he would give me his advice how i
should handle it
but then the other stuff is hiring a
private investigator i don't know where
the [ __ ] you'd find a private
investigator and just
the same when you go i mean i would
handle it like this as far as pr a
private investigator for what what the
[ __ ] would i hire private investigator
to follow you to do what
they make sense so that's what bothers
me whoever got that back to you multiple
people corroborating each other's
stories but go ahead
okay but whatever you told him about me
whether it was
how or whatever version you have in your
head that's what you told me we can call
those people after this and confirm my
story oh a thousand percent if that
makes you feel better it does make me
yeah we can do as soon as we're done
with this we will call those three
people thousand percent yep
anyways would love that would love
nothing more when you did tell version
uh rogan your version of events i just
want to know for my own peace of mind
did he believe it
i don't know he to to him it's like you
know you're never going to beat dinner
on that man i mean no regarding me and
bobby
no because i i told him it's not you
guys
okay but everything else regarding
the information that got back to me is
that you told rogan things obviously
that were very slanderous about me i'm
gonna
i want to believe that wasn't the case
put yourself in my shoes right that
anyone you knew
and you heard that they went to rogan
and said that you were a thief a gold
digger and that you were responsible for
criminal behavior on reddit things like
that would you like that no and how
would you handle that i would
now i'd call you direct
i'd call you dragon like what the [ __ ]
are you doing yeah i'm telling you clyah
i know you don't know me that did not
happen
okay
okay
i i don't believe you but thank you for
for for attempting to make me believe
that's all i can do i don't know
now you might be thinking this all
sounds insane brennan kind of sounds
like an idiot right now there's no way
that
tiger belly has been fueling all this
hate on the fire in the kid's subreddit
what wild accusations this is
here's his proof here's what he's saying
that he has
he's saying his team
was looking into some things on the
reddit
and or no it wasn't his team this is
where it gets kind of confusing he's
saying that's that there was an
investigation into the subreddit because
there are some videos
of child abuse that were just dropped
into that subreddit that have really
nothing to do with maybe the situation
and so some people are investigating
those illegal videos on that subreddit
and during the process of that found
that
one of the top six accounts for posting
activity on the subreddit that ip
address was traced basically back to
tiger belly
it's his claim and that they gave they
provided 300 pages of evidence over the
last six years this ip address or this
email traced back to tiger belly was
basically responsible for fueling the
hate
on this fire in the kids subreddit which
um
is very
hateful
kind of funny but definitely crosses the
line in a few ways uh subreddit
dedicated basically to anti-brendan
slander
kalila has been asking to see these
documents for weeks and weeks and
brendan has not been able to send them
because he claims this is an ongoing
investigation and it would be illegal
for them to possess the documents but
he's more than willing to show them
after the show on his phone
kaleila does not seem to believe that
he's going to show them bobby seems a
little more trusting
that's kind of where we left it you guys
are saying you have nothing to do with
it right so but at the time
i was so upset because you've always
been nice to me oh you've always been
nice to me we don't know each other but
you've always been nice to me so i was
so upset because if it's someone random
that's whatever
that's what they're gonna do but
somebody that i know i was so upset i
expected from somebody i don't know but
somebody that i assume i know
that's where this stems from
the anger i cannot emphasize how upset i
was and hurt and deeply hurt because
again
i don't think you guys have anything to
do with it
but where hold up hold on
i have i have the proof here here's the
thing did you wish your briefcase yeah i
don't need a break
i don't need a briefcase i wish i could
laugh at that yeah i don't have a
briefcase i have it all on my phone the
reason i can't send it to you because
the ongoing investigation
i can't on the investigation for the
child abuse thing for there's six counts
on there that you're talking about
pedophiles you're talking about horrible
[ __ ]
okay it's bigger than me
but they're gonna that's gonna be dealt
with
my thing for you
do whatever you want with this whatever
you want i
i'm good man it's horrible and i want to
squash between us do what and let me get
this out bob i know you want to talk
i'll show you
the stuff that i have
you guys figure out what you want to do
with it
this is what's interesting
again i don't think that you can you
show me now
i'll show you that when we we'll blur
this off because we want to know because
like i'll show you how to show that let
you actually showed us something you
never did
well yeah i can i can show it to you
here's the thing
this is what's interesting explain this
however you want
when i notified you guys of the
harassment and going back to tiger belly
that account stopped posting
took the tiger belly email off and
changed it it's never posted again do
you know how reddit works
no
so you seem to have very clear
convictions about this alleged
occurrence from my company
all the while not really knowing how
reddit posting works brendan so that's a
little bit well this this team note i
promise you this team knows okay
we've been asking you to speak with this
team and
here's what i have to say about this
from my end
here
from my end
it looked foolish for you to be this
fragile over something some three girls
sat on a podcast it looked foolish so in
my end the way i understand it is we
need to come up with a bigger story
about kalila to incriminate so that my
reaction to that trash tuesday talk
doesn't seem insane
no that's how i respond you're giving me
too much credit you give me too much
credit
are you getting way too much i don't you
think i'd wanna
again i don't want this drama i've been
harassed for six years guys six years
but i think that it makes sense that
someone who has been harassed for six
years would feel like he's on the back
foot and would swing in this way
it makes sense to me i would only swing
if they gave if this team who has
nothing to do with comedy know you guys
didn't show me this stuff if that is in
an active investigation right now and
that is the reason why you cannot show
us that information no i can't show you
i can't i can't send you that the
documents okay physically have them in
your possession so they can show it to
you right now when we get off i can show
you as soon as we get done i will show
you all the [ __ ] i have
you better spit shake on that brendan i
mean why wouldn't i yeah i mean because
i've been asking it for weeks yeah and
i've been asking to meet i feel like
you've long played me uh you've been
asking me to meet in person no i've been
i tried where is this where where is
this thing where is this thing and
you're like i'm busy maybe tomorrow
i'm busy just maybe i'm just the dogs
because it's like i'm busy because
here's the thing with the docks it's
like they're either not real or we have
someone that somehow got a hold and
hacked us we just want to know for
ourselves right and you should but
that's why it's very important
but and here's my thing
i'm not accusing anybody in here
but let's say in some weird world it's
somebody you you know you're associating
you had no idea what's happening
i still don't give a [ __ ] i just want to
stop yeah
that's it
you deny then that you felt under attack
by the girls and that you had to double
down and create this reddit drama like
you deny that i swear on my kids okay so
you you're my kids you're insisting
that's two separate um things and not
not
it just so happens that five days after
the live show there are reddit
accusations about me i swear on my life
okay it's very i agree very convenient
very mysterious mysterious i agree okay
my path forward
i'm telling you i there's nothing i love
more on this planet than my kids okay i
swear on my kids lives
okay that this team
yeah
brought up the tiger belly email okay
okay i i just love that you keep talking
about it team and nothing has been
produced
he has it right i have it right here
you're gonna see it we're gonna see it
and then once we see it okay allegedly
i'm going to show you
as soon as we get our fear
it's a little unfair though we don't
want to talk about this again but
this is what we can do okay
we can re we can
look at it right and when he leaves if
you want to come back on and talk about
what we saw then we can do that are you
okay with that
sure yeah i mean i mean it depends how
you go about it no i mean the way i'm
gonna go about it is um
if there's levity to it
and there is something that we need to
investigate we'll talk about that you
know i mean at this point it's like um
because what like let's just
i don't know what uh how it works but
i'm pretty sure that somebody could
create an email with the name tiger
belly but be different not with the
official email
but all of you guys sound just like
boomers don't know anything about reddit
that's what you callin and shobs sound
like you're always the [ __ ]
you don't even know how it works i don't
either but at least i'm not claiming to
be at this point in the video if you're
even still watching dude you're probably
like this drama kind of sucks like it's
between brad and shop who you might not
really like and really it's just between
him and kalila like bobby's not even
really involved in this so one of the
better things to come out of this one of
the actually funny things to come out of
this is tim dillon and louis j gomez
commentating on the la podcast scene and
this drama and the gringo poppy and
really just letting it fly and being
comedians dude these guys get it this
this is
i'm happy this all happened because of
these reactions this is what we need to
get back to dude not like this petty
little drama
of like like subtweeting people on
podcasts and [ __ ] this stuff this is
real comedy
that people [ __ ] with
yeah he went on tiger belly
and bobby lee's white
stuffed him like a turkey she just ran
in yeah
yeah she was like after all this [ __ ]
yeah she said you said this you said
this you said this none of this is true
like yeah
yeah
she's just warm like a puppet dude it's
wild all over james they're busy in that
kitchen dude orange chicken's flying
baba
it's all the [ __ ] that he said they
think they speak shabanee is this what
they call it
can we play word association la comic
scene sure all right ready
you should just fire it off don't be a
[ __ ] whitney cummings
drugs
bobby lee
korean
i mean it's the first thing that comes
to mind ryan cowan
ruffia
gringo poppy
kind of
brilliant of brilliantly brilliantly
funny in a way that no comedy special
has ever been
because it's it's mysterious in a way
because you're looking at it and you're
going like there's a lot of choices made
and you don't know why those choices
were made of course
of course yeah the comedy store uh
fine
[Music]
that's it i can't name another word i
mean that's you know yeah but here's
what's amazing about the gringo poppy
this is what's truly amazing about it
okay
you're watching it
and you're in kind of it's it's
you're in a little bit of
disbelief because it is
i i wonder and i know he's trying to get
good at stand up and i respect the hell
out of that the question is what did it
have to be a special
no
that's the real question no
no it didn't yeah and i'm not one of
these guys who like there's nothing like
this that's not [ __ ] he's a nice guy and
i know he's trying to be you know like
but the question is with that particular
thing you go did that have to be i said
this on real-life podcast he should have
friends go because here's the thing he
is a charming dude right yes um and he i
think
i don't know at all you know but i think
there's probably something he's probably
funny he probably makes his friends
laugh right yeah i think that he's
really great at podcasting on that
specific show for that audience yeah
which they want mma there's an audience
of people in america that want what he
does and he does it for them i am not
that audience of course but that's fair
but that's fair and here's the thing
yeah we we all go out because i don't
care about you everyone stinks at comedy
for the first five ten years twenty
years
kind of gay and dumb yeah let's be
honest it's
when i watch brendan do that
it's like i i i go here's a big tough
guy
who i should just see in a ferrari and
he should be able to rip people's faces
off with his catcher mid hands and i see
him running around the stage going
i go you're gay now you become gay you
were you why are you gay he was
a [ __ ] knight he was a no he was he
was not he was a knight
and now he's a jester now he's dead
he's a gay man he's a fully gay man
and you go what why
what is this disease of maybe they
should come out next week what is it
you're six foot six you're an adonis you
could beat up 99 of the people who look
forward and [ __ ] women and you don't
have to [ __ ] these skanks at the comedy
store
[ __ ] hot women annie letterman
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you and he
instead he's fully gay
on stage in dallas in front of 45 people
being like the lies
is that my door
it's just
it's puzzling the whole drama that's
going on in the la podcast scene it's
one of the gayest things i've ever seen
this is like high school level drama
where they're like calling each other
and they're talking [ __ ] and they're
threatening each other and it's like
guys in new york drama is everyone of
you can't afford your rent yeah so it's
actually real drama like the new york
podcast scene is somebody being like i
am homeless it's it's a weird thing yeah
it's a weird thing how everyone is so
poor in new york this is people in
manchester talking [ __ ] about each other
in new york the drama is like my parents
just kicked me off my
family plan and i'm 38.
i'm 38 and i don't have a phone
my roommate moved out i was not able to
secure another roommate for that room
this month
i'm actually going to kill myself
and also like i don't really feel bad
for people that are [ __ ] millionaires
that get made fun of online i don't feel
bad for you that's right you that's
that's your [ __ ] biggest problem i
feel bad is that people on the reddit
are saying mean words are you out of
your [ __ ] mind you're a millionaire
right and you care about what somebody
on reddit says there are people that you
cannot eat yeah there are people that
don't have the money to pay their rent
they cannot get their kids insulin
right
now so those those people my
audience we know them
jeremiah watkins is doing the star map
in l.a
trying to show people
he's flipping signs he's just trying to
show people he's selling fruit with
mexicans right now on the freeway
jeremiah watkins is trying to sell
bottles of water on the 405. as for
moving forward between these two i
wouldn't expect them to be going on each
other's podcasts anytime soon i don't
think bobby is going to be on fire in
the kid very soon either it's kind of
weird that stevie weeby hasn't been on
the king and the sting in a while when
he was kind of like a main character
before that but i guess it's not that
weird you know knowing what's all going
on it seems like they both just want to
move on with their lives and their
careers and be able to work together in
a professional manner but the friendship
thing might never be there again which
makes sense you know i don't need
apology
from either of you um
i i think you should look into the
information i give to you after this and
do whatever you want with it you know
yeah and you know what guess what
brendan if there is any wrongdoing on
any part of my company true you not only
will you be the first to know we will
that
it could possibly mend all of this yeah
yeah i believe so i want you
if you if that if someone in our comment
you can [ __ ] me bro
physically you can physically [ __ ] me
dude i'm kind of hoping
i hope it's you guys
i
also want to be able to go to the laugh
factory and see you and not and do if
i'm after you at a club still be able to
do the show and bring you up on stage
and work together in a professional way
in that way right 100 right um in terms
of of brian
i don't know
and brian told me to tell you this much
i can't tell you and you see i'm finding
the kid he is so sorry it doesn't matter
i'm just telling you i know
and he admit that he's insane i agree
yeah he was level 10.
i mean it was he was level i mean i
just thinking about it makes me tremble
guys it was a phone call
we had to clear some stuff up i think
there's some misunderstanding people
weren't listening
i apologized immediately after and and
bobby and i spoke
and i he read me the riot act he's mad
at me i apologized way before any of
this i wasn't i didn't did this stuff
didn't happen and then i apologize i
apologize i like the day after i called
you called again yeah you sent a text
yeah you called yeah i want this to be
very clear it's not like like man i'm
getting a lot of [ __ ] for this you were
i mean i apologize i found out two days
after like i talked to bobby i apologize
yeah i don't think he's gonna accept it
but that's all i can do yes i did i i i
did everything i could um i felt
terrible be but i did not threaten
listen the other thing is people are
saying i'm a bully so i get it
you know it's all it's all good i i
didn't threaten i didn't say i was gonna
get goons i didn't threaten his life i
didn't threaten this family i did not do
that i i was yelling i was mad because i
i was defending my friend i was working
on information that i believed to be
true at the time but my mistake was not
giving him the benefit of the doubt or
talking to him and and again i'm i
apologize for that but like like i'm a
fan too hi hey hey i'm with you like i'm
with you i was texting with bobby this
morning i'm like dude like this is
getting crazy like now at this point i'm
my my family's getting threats of
violence
like then now it's gotten to the point
where my family my fiance with the baby
she's getting threats of violence and
she's afraid like it's it's fine it's
one thing if it's hate but also guys
i've been friends with bobby for a
forever yes he's mad at me i feel
[ __ ] terrible as far as the death
threats we had a conversation and i
owned up to everything and he and he
accepted my apology he still pissed at
me but he accepted my apology it was a
phone call you made a mistake you
apologized you owned up to it that's all
you can do brother that's all you can do
neither one of us handle the situation
right you know they didn't handle
situations there has been there has been
really really bad harassment and and
threats of
violence that's how this goes for a very
long time when your team
when your team sho
when i see what you're when your team
shows me
what i what i consider to be
at least activity and long-term activity
coming from that area
that's what set me off and i was like
what the [ __ ] is going on and i made now
i made them aware of that yeah they're
they're trying to get to the bottom i i
will say that they're not like no it's
just like no but they are but it hasn't
stopped i don't know it didn't seem like
they were that great of friends
beforehand what do i know so maybe it's
not that big of a loss but it is just
kind of sad to see people fighting like
this and stupid dude like just be just
be funny man like bobby didn't do the
reddit [ __ ] i'm confident saying that
you know
just relax just have a good time like
tim dillon said this stuff's so gay so
that's it that's the drama thank you for
for watching this whole thing it was
kind of a beast of a video because it's
a lot of moving parts it's hard to
explain and the funniest part is
what i found after cutting all these
clips hours of making this video
the the result of it all is that this is
so stupid subscribe to joke world stay
in the comedy loop the first media brand
dedicated solely to following stand-up
and comedians and comedians podcasts and
their reactions and getting everything
that you need to know from the world of
comedy and from one channel subscriber
joke world follow us on instagram we're
saying everyone free stickers if you dm
us you'll get your free joke world
stickers in the mail right away thanks
for watching we'll see you wednesday
with another episode the joke world
podcast the guest josh potter anyway
that's my two cents um well i love you
man i i wish i could
[Music]
you